s'il ne veut pas qu'on le reconnaisse
c'est parce qu'il a déjà payé le prix
fort pour ce qu'il est s'il n'est pas
dit si c'est parce que les martiniquais
ont encore plus de mal que lui à
s'exprimer publiquement
jérémy 27 ans est homosexuel il y a cinq
ans alors qu'il vivait dans l'hexagone
et travailler dans une grande entreprise
il a vu le visage de la haine ancien
responsable découvrir que j'étais
homosexuel
je suis tout ça c'est un comportement
totalement changé il a profité de
chiffres il fait des choses qui ont
dévalué de ce fait je suis entré dans
une espèce de spirale infernale vie dure
et puis relativement mal comme vous êtes
allé je crois si j'ai bien compris
jusqu'à faire une tentative de suicide
exactement pourquoi est-ce que c'était
insupportable c'est que c'est avant tout
une année on est la seule à vous
expliquer c'est moralement c'est
difficile pour eux de tous les jours des
hordes de remontrances de chercheurs
âgés des plannings fait c'est vraiment
plein de petits actes vous
doublement gagnants malheureusement et
puis j'ai changé de 800 commencer je me
suis éloigné de lui en fait on peut se
déplacer
j'ai réussi à prendre de la page plus
vouloir partir c'est ce qui a sauvé
jérémy arrivé ici il rencontre une
communauté qu'il n'avait pas dans son
petit village d'origine
l'homosexualité n'est pourtant pas
forcément plus facile à vivre pour les
jeunes martiniquais le départ dans un
sens ou dans l'autre et souvent une
libération
toute la famille tous quand les
personnes en question ne sait même pas
que toute sa famille ne sait pas ce
qu'il ne peut pas lire une vaut pas le
droit de perdre roi roger familiale j'ai
des amis aussi c'est terrible c'est plus
difficile pour certains et pas d'autres
a que moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui ce
parti en métropole à cause de ça ce
sentiment d'incompréhension de roger
c'est en partie à cause de ça il ne vous
c'est vraiment vraiment court au mur
vraiment comme les jeunes martiniquais
qu'il connaît jérémy ne veut pas
repartir vers sa région d'origine je
n'ai commencé à vivre qu'en arrivant en
martinique dit il je n'ai commencé à
être libre qui si je ne suis pas une
bête à abattre aujourd'hui situation
généralement de jeu comme ça sélestat
c'est pas un choix ce n'est pas du tout
un show dans l'hexagone les agressions
homophobes sont repartis à la hausse
depuis 2015